okay so the topic of today are spheres
the the spheres of ecology so let's go
ahead and get started
okay well let's look at the geosphere
first the geo geosphere is really
defined as the earth itself you know you
look at the diagram you can see the
various layers of the earth itself
so the geosphere being the rocks and the
minerals uh the magma the lava you know
flowing from volcanoes the forms that we
see the the continents the sea floor uh
everything below earth's surface you
know this is what makes up our geosphere
so the geosphere is constantly being
reshaped you may know that the the
crust of the earth is broken into these
various plates if you've heard of plate
tectonics before and the plates are
bumping and rubbing and moving all the
time causing earthquakes so the
geosphere is constantly being reshaped
and so if you've heard of pangaea before
pangaea is this large land mass of all
the the super continents here about 250
million years ago but because the earth
is constantly being reshaped
over the years the continents are
dividing
and separating here we are 145 million
years ago
and here we are present day so
the continents as we see them today i
mean that's what our earth our geosphere
looks like today but it's still in
motion
as the earth continues continually
changes and reshapes itself
also the geosphere is shaped by natural
processes such as erosion you know wind
blowing can cause erosion rain water can
cause erosion but the grand canyon you
know wasn't always so grand
it's been carved by the actions of
erosion by the actions of the colorado
river going through it so these are
factors that can shape the geosphere
and within the geosphere nutrients are
released
by organisms and nutrients are stored
and used by life you know you see the
tree roots in these pictures here in
this picture
and so the roots will of course absorb
nutrients that are stored in the soil
and once the nutrients are in the plants
then the nutrients get into living
things by moving up the food chain you
know animals that eat uh the seeds that
this tree produces and then
carnivores will come along and eat the
herbivores and so nutrients are released
and stored within the geosphere as well
well if we look at the next sphere the
the atmosphere
the layer of gases that surround the
planet
and if you look at this picture right
here here are some of the gases that are
in earth's atmosphere and these gases
are going to be used to build nutrients
that living organisms might need notice
the carbon dioxide well that carbon
dioxide is used during photosynthesis to
build glucose which is an energy
molecule that we all need a nutrient
uh h2o the water is also taken in during
photosynthesis and is used
by plants and other autotrophs to build
glucose
the n2 the nitrogen that's in the
atmosphere you know this is taken in and
and used to make dna the nitrogen-based
building blocks the atcg adenine thymine
cytosine guanines these are nitrogen
bases where the nitrogen comes from the
n2 that's in the sky
and so don't forget there's also just
oxygen o2 that is used to breathe uh you
know in respiration
and so breathable oxygen so these gases
that are part of the atmosphere are used
to build nutrients in living organisms
so if we summarize photosynthesis really
quick you know there's really three main
ingredients of photosynthesis sunlight
carbon dioxide from the sky
and water
those three ingredients will be used by
autotrophs autotrophs like plants and
then through the process of
photosynthesis glucose or the molecule
six carbons 12 hydrogens six oxygens
glucose and oxygen waste are released
into the atmosphere the glucose is used
by the the the plants itself
for energy needs
okay so let's move on to the next sphere
the the hydrosphere this is defined as
all the waters on earth's surface
so we look at this picture here and it
looks like a probably a generalized
picture you've seen before of the water
cycle you know you've heard the
expression what goes up must come down
so water will cycle through
uh through the planet uh and in making
up what we call the hydrosphere
we're looking at the water on the
surface of the planet we're talking
about of course the oceans the seas
we're talking about the ice the frozen
ice the poles we're talking about
groundwater the water that's under the
ground that a lot of people uh use for
drinking water we're talking about you
know the moisture in this in the sky the
clouds all of this makes up the
hydrosphere
and as water cycles from the sky to the
ground to the oceans back up to the sky
to the ground to the oceans as water
cycles of course it's used by all life
for a variety of cellular needs earlier
we mentioned that water
is one of the main ingredients of during
photosynthesis and so water will be used
during photosynthesis to help create
glucose
and that's how autotrophs produce their
their food
if we move on move on to the next sphere
the biosphere this is the portion of the
earth where we find life what i want to
stress is this is not the entire this is
not the entire planet
this is a small
uh thin slice of of the planet of the
crust particularly
if we look at this picture right here
you get a good idea of the biosphere
most life is found in this red region
right here about six
six thousand meters above sea level and
about 500 meters below sea level that's
where we find all uh i'm sorry that's
where we find most living things on
earth now that's not the entire
biosphere the world record holder for
the
uh
for the uh for altitude is this vulture
right here that if you look on the scale
i think uh has been spotted in flight uh
10 000 meters about 10 000 meters above
sea level which is amazing
and in terms of depth it's this little
microscopic organism benthic
foraminifera which have been found i
believe in the mariana trench the
deepest trench in the ocean but this is
the entire biosphere from the top end of
the vulture to the bottom end of the
benthic foraminifera although most life
lives in that shaded red area right
there but that's where we find life this
is what we call the biosphere
and we
remind ourselves that nutrients
can be obtained from the other spheres
for instance when we look at this
formula here for photosynthesis
the carbon dioxide comes from the
atmosphere from the sky
the water used during photosynthesis
that comes from the hydrosphere
plants of course then do photosynthesis
they make sugar
but the light the light comes from outer
space okay
the sugar that they create during
photosynthesis that that sugar enters
into the biosphere because it's
available for other organisms to consume
and the oxygen that is released during
photosynthesis well that's released into
the atmosphere so we start to see i hope
how all these spheres are kind of
interconnected with one another
and if we looked at a process called
cellular respiration you might not be
too familiar with cellular respiration
yet but this is the process where cells
make their energy that they need to
perform their daily actions and notice
how it begins with a molecule of glucose
well that comes from the biosphere
an autotroph a plant probably made that
molecule of glucose and so now look at
the next part the six o2s the oxygen
that came from the atmosphere and then
through the process of cellular
respiration notice six molecules of
water are created where that water
enters into the biosphere
the carbon dioxide that is enters into
the atmosphere you know we exhale carbon
dioxide waste into the sky into the
atmosphere and then the energy that's
created during cellular respiration that
enters into the biosphere so again i
hope you start to see how all these
spheres are kind of connected and
related to one another
and so water again we said earlier water
is often obtained that water is obtained
from the hydrosphere and so water being
one of the key
components of life on earth we see how
the hydrosphere with water is connected
to for instance the biosphere
but the other spheres as well but just
to point out water because it is so
fundamental to all life on earth
okay so here's a quick little review of
some of the things we talked about i
hope you can subscribe down below that
actually does help
if you're in my biology class you know
try these questions i'm happy to check
your answers before class or after class
one day so thanks for watching